تمثل صناعه منتجات تفتيح البشره 50% من
سوق منتجات العنايه بالبشره وبلغت قيمتها
السوقيه اكثر من سبعه مليار دولار في عام
2021 مع توقعات بان تصل الى حوالي 14.6
مليار دولار بحلول الفين واحد وثلاثين
بمعدل ثانوي مركب يبلغ 7.7% من عام 2022
الى 2031 ونسبه المبيعات الاجماليه من
المتوقع ان تصل في عام 2024 الى 31.2
مليار دولار واظهرت دراسه اجرتها منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان 40% من النساء في الصين
يستخدمن كريمات تفتيح البشره بانتظام وتصل
هذه النسبه الى 61% بالهند وسبعه وسبعين
في نيجيريا كما اظهرت دراسه اخرى لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه في عام 2017 ان اكثر من
70% من النساء في مصر يستخدمن مستحضرات
التبييض بافراط كما كشفت هذه الدراسه ان
هناك فتيات في عمر العشر اعوام استخدمنا
المستحضرات بغرض تبييض بشرتهم